ma chi ti credi di essere
[ __ ] [ __ ] timori se la famiglia
la madre e la sorella razzia la nuora e
la suocera madonna quanto
raccapricciante la mia ombra dietro lft
ragazza nella spe devo far partire il
gioco sono che cazzo il commento perso
gioco marche a [ __ ] si può iniziare
nicchia 2 milioni d'iscritti inizio
manco iniziali video con mamma mia che
schifo noi ragazzi siamo partiti non ho
ancora capito il senso le ville rai
ovvero cruz rift fantasy è bellissimo
scoprire ste cose cioè non ci avevo
voglia di fare un horror
meno male che però quello stilistico si
è ancora peggio che è realistica che la
pioggia borchia tra io mi sembrano buoni
essere bagnato
ah no quello era il mio pc che mi sembra
tipo dalla cosa di auto dal fantastico
messo ma mi fai capire
diamo entra devo entrare nella stanza va
bene permesso sono piove anche dentro
cano chiudi la porta grazie per fare le
buone maniere
lì però va ragazzi che le cose sotto non
le leggo cioè fantastico non devo
togliermi rock blues per vedere cosa
fare il suo gioco parte è la madonna già
chiari è la casa di franchi e fed e
quando dico la parola frankenstein si
mette a piovere l'obiettivo quale
dovrebbe essere in teoria parte quello
di girare a caso per casa e la cucina
come fantastico datemi la nutella dove
la nutella stranzi un qualcosa di un po
più allegra dentro la casa no deve
essere per forza tetra sono siete
contenti va bene ma ripensandoci vado a
giocare a super mario in salotto là
dentro ci devo entrare no perché non
c'entra non mai ma neanche se mimì
tortura non solo che frankenstein
oddio ha funzionato vieni che ti chiede
bisogna dire frank insieme piove
fantastico chi è stato a far casino e
piano di sochi c'è chi c'è i quali qua
perfetto non entriamo entrame 38 c'è una
tizia ciao zio edito da far casino prima
eri tu che avevi le pen madonna che
sento comunque bordello
oddio sia benedetta la palla a svegliare
ma è rincoglionita scusate perchè devo
sentire dei rumori dovunque vada
tranquilla tesoro è solo televisore che
che in sassata nato il problema si
risolve c'è un tecnico di satana per
caso a ti riprendi fa la sporca ciò
molto basse o dio ha quindi posso
scatenò fantastico per vedere devo
scattare le foto perché se no non vedo
ragazzi tenete presente che io non vedo
quello che vedete voi vedo molto meno
tesoro stai tranquilla fai un
fondoschiena da paura oh merda c'è un
piano di sopra
no vabbè ragazzi ma la cosa più horror
che abbia mai visto non posso se vi
sfrutta qualcosa davanti mentre scatto
giuro che bp o a schiaffi
salve che cazzo sei tu ciao fratello
eccoti qua e che stai facendo casino da
ore si ascoltano mai l'ho fotografato
[Applauso]
perché si è spenta la luce pure in
camera mia
oh mio dio canicani fermi aiuto accendi
accendi per cortesia
qualora chi la [ __ ] ai ragazzi è
stata una tragedia
l'ho rifatto ho messo la difficoltà
altissima visto che prima sono riuscito
bene adesso non col cazzo
fatevi vedere che riesco a tirar fuori
adesso magari ce la faccia che non lo
voglio sapere che cos'è fatemi aprire le
porte per me il social attraverso sono
persone in casa mia il problema è che
non c'è un'altra luce
avete una salve senti tu mf dovrebbe
essere mia figlia questa qua c'è anche
una figlia fate vedi che non uso di
condom bengala
spiegami pacchettini dei bengala in casa
scrivo fammi capire
oddio non ho schiacciato stavo
scherzando tasca tesoro ha dato una
sistemata in soffitta nasce o mio dio
io propongo una cosa sì come adesso ciò
lascia e la fotocamera che che fa il
flash
io andrei i sotterranei cerruti che gli
ottima idea collega non toccare mia
figlia porco 26
eccoti [ __ ] vieni qua velo di
corsa da secoli vieni qua che cazzo fai
prende a cazzotti la lampada che il caso
ha fatto lampo ma spiegami sei una [ __ ]
merda merda merda merda merda merda o
merda
dov'è dove cazzo andata è sparita e
scompare aiuta se ne andranno anche
sulla porta non chiudere la porta perché
mia figlia è sempre lì dentro quindi
grazie ai toccata
o dio santo grazie perfetto tesoro sei a
posto non è da mia moglie vero no perché
mi batte il cuore che sta succedendo è
esaltato qua tranquilli tranquilli è
saltato un quadro dove un altro poi a di
merda dov'è michele do fuoco volta è se
non ti piace l'arte che io attacco ai
muri tra attacchi al cazzo hai capito
l'aqua degli attacco io e gli stacchi tu
ma chi ti credi di essere
[ __ ] [ __ ] timori se la famiglia
la madre e la sorella la zia la nuora e
la suocera non sono morti come sarà
ancora vivo come impossibile è scesa
dalle scale tipo leso c ok ci penso io
accendiamo le luci incendiamo le luci
che non si sa mai accendiamo anche la tv
che c'è gusto perfetto così almeno stai
tranquilla ma poiché casa ha già
frankestein casa dell'amica è questa c'è
nel senso proprio in mezzo alla man non
c'è niente c'è una statua pure brutta
macabra complimenti per l'arredamento
zio veramente io sto aspettando che
spunti un altra volta perché le do fuoco
di giuro che vedo fuori da ragazzi nella
capigliatura e via via via via
il perfetto porca [ __ ] bastarda ladra
porca put son rotto i [ __ ] mi sono
rotto i sei morto ma dai ma veramente
non l'avrei mai detto si io guarda che
grazie per meno del 3 grazie mille
ragazzi concludo che l'episodio e start
è stato una merda ma proprio una merda
forte e sempre un piacere scoprire che
esistono videogiochi cazzuti e reti
madonna che capelli che schifo è la cosa
più horror di tutto il video ragazzi
sono i miei capelli in questo momento
che i ragazzi non credo che l'episodio
spero che ha visto che sia piaciuto un
pollice all'insù per la pizza che era
una [ __ ] alla fine consente ragazzi se
vi è piaciuta questo momento è un mi
piace anche a faccia di facebook e come
nei video tornare stizia nei 120 di sky
ci vediamo in questo video sperando non
sia sullo blues lista almeno bello da
ragazzi che cazzo